Since we just discussed application
domain, machine domain, and the specificiation,
let's make sure that these concepts are well understood. To do that,
I'm going to use a quiz, and I would like for you
to refer to the figure that we just discussed that I'm also
reproducing here on a small scale on the right. And then
referring to the figure, you should indicate for each of the items
that I'm going to show you here shortly. Whether they belong to
the machine domain. In this case, we're going to put a one next
to the icon. The application domain, in this case you should
put two. Or their intersection, and in this case you should
put three. So this is the lists of items. So let
me read it. An algorithm sorts a list of books in alphabetical
order by the first author's name. A notification of the arrival
of a message appears on a smart watch. An employee wants to
organize a meeting with a set of colleagues. And finally, a
user clicks a link on a web page. So again, put 1,
2, or 3 here in these lots, depending on whether you think that these items
belong to the machine domain, the application
domain, or their intersection. So, their specification, here.